il suffit de regarder les maillots des
compétiteurs pour se sentir moins très
loin parfois australie nouvelle zélande
corée japon l'élite du tir sportif de
vitesse plus connue internationalement
sous l'acronyme y psc est rassemblée ici
à l'heure de la pause les immenses
couloirs du centre ressemble à ceux du
métro aux heures de pointe
la discipline est très populaire
l'attrait pour la discipline selon les
tireurs je vais me faire le rapporteur
de ce que j'entends
c'est parce que c'est une dynamique qui
nécessite une grande coordination et qui
permet d'exprimer
le tir sous forme de vitesse et sous
forme de précision lors d'épreuves qui
sont relativement assez complexe mais
qui leur permettent donc de développer
l'ensemble de leurs qualités
une énorme organisation des arbitres
internationaux par dizaines cinquante
mille feuille de match archivés et un
hall d'exposition digne des salons
professionnels c'est là que nous
retrouvons notre sextuple champion du
monde
eric beau-frère qui se lance dans un
nouveau défi tu encore au courant dans
une autre catégorie
il est l'un de ceux qui peuvent
aujourd'hui se payer ce luxe
on n'est pas nombreux en europe à être
on va dire semi professionnel parce
qu'on n'est pas on n'est pas rémunéré
dans le sens où
on touche un salaire et puis on n'a que
ça à faire non il faut quand même encore
travailler sur le côté mais
effectivement la discipline sportive
nous coûte plus rien car il existe
l'intérieur de la compétition une
multitude de sous catégories selon l'âge
la même des points de règlement pour
simplifier disons que le spectacle est
accessible à tous puisqu'il s'agit de
regarder tirer sur des cibles selon des
règles propres à chaque stand chaque
compétiteur devra passer par la totalité
de ses stands afin de pouvoir prétendre
à un classement dans sa catégorie
ce sera comme ça jusqu'à samedi